4日
あ
うっ
宣伝です今 c の本気眉ですね
8調整に僕の名前があります俺もずにマガジンで3だよ
まあよかったらマガジンやってみてくださいちゃんとカラーで載ってるんで
入線レンガテラーに今日は僕の特技を教えようと思いますみなさんトーク人があります
か僕はねは言っちゃうとこうこれといったと気がないんです本当に得意じゃないます
けどず長い降ってたのとは幼稚園から中学校まで
ピアノ習ってたくらいであと特にこれといって何か出来るとかそういうのはないんです
よね本当にそんな僕にもなんかすごい特技があったりで
俺はねこれで結構で当たり前のことだと思ってたんだけどいろんな人に聞く限り
当たり前じゃなかった日だよ最近よくそれをやると
で旦那様御であること言われてなく普通みんな誰と思ってたことが実は僕にしかなかっ
た的なそう
ゆうやつ寝綿棒です僕の鳥は綿棒
耳に入れると必ず素敵が出ます
はって思ったでしょ間違いないそれが普通の反応だよ経度でる人もいるらしいんだけど
基本的にみんなでなりません
で最低それのなんかはと空室してというものに気づいたので
今日は皆の前で性器をしてみようと思います
結果もまあまあ見てるくださいいきます
ちょっと耳に出るからね
ふーんずっとしっ
あれこっちなこっちこっちがなどっちでもなるんですよね
ん
これい綿棒かメンバーがいいかなんないかもしれないしません両方やろリョービ名いる
アッん
はっはぁー
何た方がないこれは1回スイッチ入るとと版だけなんですよなぜなら今日なんないよ
鋸南ねーぞ
こっちじゃねぇこれいいやつかな
そんなの関係だけ
はわーなんでできない深刻にやばいぞこれ
詰まってるちょっと多分黒い名もずダメだから白いの買ってくる
うっ
よし
白い白い方です俺できなくたラモスと思ったねーよ
なんかきゅん者なる気がしないんだよ
winner it 無理しちゃダメやっぱり飲んでたらおかしくね2男のになぁ席で
泣けるっと
いや深刻な問題だこれ
moon
結構飽きられモードなんですけどよりでるのにおりいろんな人の前に出してきたも席な
んで
リーダーいった誰かでねぇほっつきんだよ
わっをしっかりしで大雨ちょっと痛いみんな耳かきはちゃんと気をつけてやろうね
入ったちょっと結構響いてる様が耳負傷したちょっと待って
お母さんにでもシワもします確認したいことが一つあるんですけど俺さぁ
耳かきしたらさ俺さー
もしもし俺さぁ見かけしたらさせ機に出るね
別でしょ
ありがとうございます
ご予算ヤブヤム
お疲れ様です
容赦証明書っ
b
しています